retrouvez notre envoyé spécial en en
ukraine gulliver crack bonjour gulliver
on me disait l'offensive russe se durcit
gullivar
willy à un climat de grosses angoisses
je pense ce matin en ukraine on a tous
vu ces images satellites de cette
colonne de tanks qui avancent vers kiev
et les informations comme quoi la russie
après une légère
pause dans l'offensive hier c'était un
peu moins intense surtout sur carrière
que ce n'était juste reculer pour mieux
sauter que après avoir subi des échecs
et les choses ne sont pas allées
exactement selon le plan du blick strict
que vladimir poutine avait en tête
maintenant ils regroupent et il prépare
une offensive bien plus musclé vous avez
parlé de kiev a requis vingt personnes
marioupol ces villes là semble être
effectivement les cibles les plus
importantes les plus stratégiques mais
il y à des attaques des tirs de
roquettes sur beaucoup d'autres endroits
du pays aussi je pense que il est
important aussi de souligner quand on
parle des archives et que tout le monde
ce matin regarde ces images horribles de
cette roquette qui tombe en plein centre
ville sur le bâtiment du gouvernement
régional kharkiv est une ville
russophone vladimir poutine au début de
cette offensive disait qu'il voulait et
qu'il fallait protéger les russophone
d'ukraine de ces soi-disant
nationalistes ukrainiens symboliquement
le fait que la plus grande ville
russophone arc yves d'ukraine est traité
de la sorte
ça parle beaucoup je pense de ce que du
vrai visage de vladimir poutine gilbert
crack vous vous trouvez actuellement
dans un village à 250 km environ de kiev
dans une zone rurale quelle est la
situation sur place
la situation même ici loin des points
des combats les plus importantes et
quand même absolument l'ambiance d'un
pays en guerre il y à des checkpoints
mise en place par des volontaires à
l'entrée de chaque village plusieurs
même dans le village de 400 habitants où
me trouve je pense qu'il y a 3
checkpoint on a l'impression que tout le
monde s'est engagé pour organiser cette
résistance pour être prêt si les russes
arrivent il y a bien sûr une inquiétude
quant aux effets d'une situation comme
ça où vous avez une population
soudainement armée puisque le port
d'armes par les civils a été légalisé
très en colère très traumatisée n'ayant
pas forcément pour beaucoup d'entre eux
une expérience militaire et la
possibilité de dérapages et je pense que
c'est avec cela en tête que les
autorités ukrainiennes ont interdit la
vente d'alcool sur tout le pays merci
beaucoup gulliver craag envoyé spécial
ans en ukraine merci